es geht um einen flug der mir nicht
komplett erstattet wurde aufgrund corona
im mai sollte ich von granja nach
münchen fliegen mit der kontrolle
und da hat euch das ja bruder
aufgetreten ist konnte der flug nicht
stattfinden und kann da hat man jetzt
nach monaten den betrag zwar zurück
erstattet allerdings fehlen mir immer
noch 54 euro also sie haben nur einen
teil bezahlt und ich hätte jetzt gerne
von euch bewusst ist das rechtens
ich bin der meinung es müsste mir der
komplette betrag zurückgezahlt werden
und es bräuchte ich eure hilfe vielen
dank die kommt natürlich hier auch durch
an kempkens konto erstattet nicht 100%
des flugpreises zurück sondern behält
der 450 euro ein ist das okay
nein das ist nicht okay man kann sich
höchstens darüber unterhalten ob
beispielsweise portokosten abgezockter
abgezogen werden können wenn etwas per
post verschickt worden ist was
eigentlich ja total unüblich ist darüber
könnten wir vielleicht diskutieren
bei gutscheinen also wenn ich ein
gutschein akzeptiere da müssen sogar
diese kosten erstattet werden also sogar
portokosten bei dingen wo ich eben
vereinbaren dass mir das geld
zurückgezahlt wird der reisende hat ja
ein anspruch auf bargeld rückzahlung da
ist kein abzug zu lässig bis eben
mögliche porto kosten also ganz ganz
wichtig weil keiner darf irgendwas
einbehalten sondern sie bekommen 100
prozent also noch mal ein bisschen druck
machen das kann ja wohl nicht sein
wir haben konto dazu natürlich auch
angefragt aber wir haben innerhalb von
drei tagen keine antwort erhalten